[Music]
hi and welcome to episode 170 of the
weekly Google cloud platform podcast
we're doing daily episodes here at next
on the show floor right now I'm joined
by Asha how you doing Ida I am doing
great and this has been a fantastic
event it's been really really cool so
yeah we're doing daily episodes to make
sure to tune in every day but why don't
we just get straight into the interviews
that sounds like a great plan let's hear
what everyone here has to say excellent
let's do that so we're here today with
Jonathan sham customer engineering
manager and mark and Gabby we want to
know
Jonathan what is your experience and
next what do you see that you like so
I've been at next three times already
and I think we're like doubling and
growth in terms of number of attendees
and it's just super exciting to see the
ecosystem grow at the scale that it is
growing mm-hmm just the number of
buildings that we're taking over at
Moscone is a clear reflection of our
growth and I mean I'm just really
excited to see the customers the
partners the entire ecosystem the amount
of Googlers that we've been hiring as
well just to support the tremendous
needs from our customers yeah I mean
it's been super busy and there's
obviously like you said we're taking
over more space there's more showcases
here they're building up higher and
taller than they've ever been you said
earlier you know we're only but two
hours into the next 2019 now is there
anything that's caught your eye anything
you're super excited about I mean right
now we just talked about anthos that's
something that all my customers have
been talking about multi cloud hybrid
cloud flexibility agility scalability
reliability security performance all of
that the announcement around anthos I
think is going to be a really big
talking point across all our customers
especially in the enterprise space right
that's just something that they continue
to speak about is look I love Google but
also have been using other clouds as
well how can you help me leverage the
investments I've already made into
something that I can use across multiple
cloud providers so I think it's gonna be
huge for us and we've had what 20 years
of open source investment it's something
that we do that's in our DNA so I really
think that it's going to be a
really big thing across all our
customers yeah I think it's nice too
because a lot of people have been like
you said people have been really
interested in this and they've been
learning about it and Google's been
talking about it and they have a lot of
service offerings but it's kind of great
to see like the floodgates open up today
and just say here are all these cool
things they're finally here they're
ready you know for people to use you can
get started with them a lot of them are
in beta we were just talking to the
cloud run folks I think there's a lot
there that people can like get their
hands on right now
and start working with and then
hopefully kind of see like how do I
bring my business and solve more
problems with this yeah it's super
exciting I mean just walking down the
stairs the amount of time it takes to go
down the stairs is also a clear
reflection of how busy it is just like
all right are we gonna walk are we gonna
run like it was it's packed here right
now so it's exciting what do you think
about the keynote did you watch it yeah
I mean TK look he's a veteran in the
industry so watching him speak with
clarity and helping us internally as
well as externally understand the
priorities of Google cloud I mean he's a
new leader for us and so to see him put
everything together with help from Diane
Greene is very refreshing
and I think his focus on not only the
enterprise but all our customers I think
it's gonna really show in our product
showcase yeah I think there's gonna be a
lot of cool stuff coming up with next
couple days and then you know as TK
comes in and starts to like kind of
redefine what we're going for I think
we're gonna see some really really cool
stuff from Google this year yeah it's
gonna be fun
I am excited for announcements but I
can't open looking at me like you got
something you wanted to share but
there's so much stuff just where they're
just waiting and just waiting for this
stuff for the floodgates - yeah I'm just
meet here ready to tweet about it no
don't play poker that's all I gotta say
just terrible poker player like really
exciting I mean I'd love to hang out
with you more cuz then I could tell
something news coming up just watch out
well I think everyone listening
hopefully we'll get to see all these
things come out in social media
obviously if you're here you're probably
having a great time if you're not here
then come here next year yeah kind of
get all the excitement for yourself yeah
and if you're not here go bug your
account team for some passes there Oh
also there is cloud next on the air oh
yeah yeah that was our thing mark
they're still doing it this year yeah of
course yes Stephanie Stephanie Wong's
actually was on right before I walked in
here so so we've got the live streams
we've got all the recorded content some
of the sessions are gonna be live and
then you know a lot of this content is
gonna get on there on YouTube yeah fun
times ok thank you so much thank you
thank Jonathan so we're here today with
Ori and Ori can you present yourself
absolutely so I'm or Akashi I'm a
product manager on the cloud sequel team
focused on sequel server whoo
so that was just announced right yeah we
just announced it this morning in the
keynote and you probably saw our demo is
showing how you onboard on to manage
sequel server from legacy databases so
it's this a private alpha or public
alpha it's gonna be so right now it's
just a private alpha second half of this
year we're gonna go with a public beta
but for right now we're looking for
folks that are interested we already
have a set of customers but there's an
interest sheet that you can sign up for
on our website oh cool so I mean this is
something people have been asking for
for some time oh yeah I mean sequel
server has you know historically always
been in the top three databases that our
enterprise customers are using and it's
been cited time and time again as
something about folks looking to take
advantage of kind of GCPs
other services want to make sure that
they don't have to abandon their legacy
sequel server footprint behind and so
what this does is gives them the
opportunity to kind of bring it along
don't have to transform right away I
mean they could just bring it as is and
it'll run very well on our managed
service and then they can take their
time kind of re-architecting and
recreating their other solutions right
so now it's not a blocker to move to the
cloud exactly and they're just worrying
about a data
everything else correct correct so right
now cloud sequel still supports my
sequel and Postgres as well right
correct so this is you know a great
indication of how we're expanding the
portfolio for cloud sequel so you know
you can continue to expect us
you know devoting more energy into the
platform and making sure we're
compatible and hosting more databases
I am excited of all that yeah it has
been very you know exciting ride and I
know that teams work really hard to get
us here and we're super happy to have
customers start using our product
absolutely any other cool cloud sequel
related announcements that you want to
talk about I think that sequel server
taking advantage of kind of a platform
that cut sequel is already on is one of
the things that many folks take for
granted so it'd be good to call out that
you know all the same great features in
terms of like regional availability and
automatic backups and everything else
people have come to expect from cloud
sequel is also going to be available for
sequel server and so that's super
exciting that you know it's not just the
great sequel server product that folks
have been used to using but also now
enhanced with all the goodness that
comes with a cloud sequel and GCP
anything else that next year super
excited to see yeah I mean there's not
enough time in the day to see everything
you know I'm really excited with part of
the the keynote demo this morning was
the rest of our new advancements in the
windows ecosystem on GCP and so you
probably saw me demoing manage dbl is
also coming out and a bunch of other
services as well and so you know I think
we we have a really good complete story
for if you are a Windows shop today if
you have you know certain solutions that
require that ecosystem we can support
that then you know that shouldn't be a
blocker for you in adopting juicy piece
oh thank you Ori is that anything else
that you want to talk to us about cloud
sequel server no I think that's that's
my student that's plenty there's a lot
but I definitely encourage folks that
are interested we'll be releasing a lot
of information now there's a sign-up
sheet you know if you do want to
participate in our alpha and definitely
look forward to having everyone try it
out when it goes beta later this year
okay thank you thanks so much thank you
so much hi we're in the podcast house
here at gzb next today it is Tuesday in
the afternoon so some of the cool talks
have already happened like Brian's
talking earlier today and you were nice
enough to come hang out with us so can
you tell us who you are yeah absolutely
Matt Brown a Solutions Architect at
squid that spelled SKU ID were alo code
development platform and tool for all
kinds of data and platforms and yeah
happy to be here from Chattanooga
Tennessee
I know chato era yeah we love it this
Nate Cornyn and I basically get to serve
Matt everyday just kind of step my
Butler yeah nice new role in kind of an
enablement board for squid so we've been
working with kind of professional
services type stuff for the company for
the last couple of years and just like
what you're doing developer relations we
got to this point where it's like we
really need people to just focus on that
and so we kind of spun up here in the
last couple months and Google necks
happens to be the first event that we're
coming in just the capacity of we want
to see how it's done right
and we're like okay who could possibly
do this scouting mission is this way oh
yeah and you all nailed it we literally
we got delayed yesterday we had to sit
in Chattanooga Airport for a while sorry
American Airlines we had to spend the
night in dallas-fort worth and so we
finally got here today and so I don't
we've been on the floor for literally
the first thing weird yeah and boom you
just watch the house on the podcast that
looks so inviting you know it's like the
cottage and like console and gretel you
guys are gonna eat us right no no I do
not think that is on the plan because
there's plenty of snacks okay good good
good so what's one thing each of you is
looking forward to seeing while you're
here at the conference
firebase awesome choice yeah I want to
see more about the sequel databases on
oh yeah we we announced a Mabini of was
it post Brazil that managed Postgres 11
on cloud sequels beta as opposed more
which is super exciting for all of our
friends who like to have up-to-date
frameworks and tools so that they don't
have security issues we've got a lot of
Postgres junkies that's great that's
cool yeah what's one thing you want to
copy from this event that was so awesome
literally this place right here so
they've got this amazing kind of glass
house little mini cute area it's
contained and on my hand ready yeah and
just a really cool setup I took a
picture and they just waved and it was
so warm
it was so inviting and they said come
come in here talk to us and that's
amazing mm-hmm so right like that I want
to replicate that I loved looking in the
app and seeing how you can set up to
three meetings with an expert for 30
minutes that's pretty killer on and on
any topic that's just really cool I like
that a lot acting with people right yeah
yeah because ultimately it comes down to
having a real conversation about a real
problem that you're trying to solve and
you can you know we can talk about it at
a high level but ultimately it comes
down to that and that's true of this
kind of stuff too on the path the
podcast level like actual dialogue is
where stuff kind of rises to the top yep
technology is all about people despite
what everyone thinks
most of coming ask about that for sure
as far as developer relations how did
that become a thing how long has that
been a thing or how long have y'all been
at that in that role or a part of this
thing
I'll go first cuz you've been a Google
longer I've been doing deverel at Google
for about four years
Deborah's been around at Google a firm
out longer than that I think we're fast
approaching ten year mark something like
that of the developer advocate title oh
man it's close it's grass management and
we pull people from all over we like
having people with lots of different
backgrounds and the big thing is you
have to be excited about technology and
you have to be excited about talking
with people you do not have to be an
extrovert there's a super-secret there
are several folks opposed do devrel
because they have a list of topics they
can talk about and they don't have to
make small talk ever yeah so true that's
great
for us you go on and then off
yeah well it's still good stuff and you
know if you love what you talk about
that that works yep so is there
something like particularly you like
Raja talking about I'm a generalist you
got Brian and I and we are that you will
not go with fearless leaders but leaders
of some kind of our application
development outreach group there you go
and we kind of do all this stuff I am
particularly passionate about languages
programming languages I like too many of
them I tried to get everyone in the devs
on it this morning to like tell me their
favorite language and they all just kind
of stared at me so it was probably a
little early for my level of enthusiasm
it's okay I threw some dinosaur facts at
them and they still stared at me okay so
I'll just well no I want the languages
but okay Brian hey Brian why don't you
talk about what the stuff that makes you
excited because you gave a talk this
morning already
I did but I'm actually gonna Lee talked
about part of it so I did give a talk on
like how to choose between the different
compute stuff and I just get really
excited about vm's and they're kind of
considered boring tech but they're like
this amazing boring tech when they're a
slice of a data center you can have all
this cool ephemeral stuff you can do it
naturally quickly and it's the next step
for almost every real system that
already exists like you're building
something new there's a whole bunch of
stuff to look at but if you've got a
thing already probably your biggest
value step is getting into a VM
sanika experience is that the GCE
is that well that is compute engine we
will compute in tune exactly nicely it
can't be like acronym check hey Brian
did I see TK saying something about
really big vm's this morning yeah got we
got some really big VMs how big a VM can
we get now so for comparison you can get
400 some V CPUs and almost 12 terabytes
of RAM soon and for context I wouldn't
looked up like the biggest hard drive
you could like get on the internet and
buy and that's 14 terabytes see pretty
soon you may be able to like turn on a
VM with about as much RAM is the biggest
hard drive you can buy into like okay is
there can we talk costs at all rough
ballpark is there any idea what is that
it adds up when you get that big like is
we basically do the prices by getting
about a memory over time and by CPU so
like it adds up but you can also get
those machines for a really short amount
of time so it's fun to buy it and keep
it forever yeah we both we still go to
the 10-minute right first 10 minutes in
that every minute after something like
yeah so it's like I think it's even
maybe to the second but at the first 10
minute for 10 minutes I know that so
make many many small jobs cool and don't
make them talk to each other in infinite
loops that just rack up the infinite
loops are just done really bad yeah so
are there any talks that you know you're
gonna be going to while you're here if
you looked at the a better yet you know
we all be honest so Graham I do this is
it okay to keep it I'm not just gonna
throw it out yeah I love it she's
describing like a relic of Abbas days so
I was looking for what there's a little
bit of fish out of water for me because
I don't come from a development
background and I got into application
development through our product which is
awesome yeah what is your background
team don't come from a development
background either cool cool all right
well then great so I'm a fish out of
water with other fish that are out of
water or maybe it's just a new pond I
don't know I think I think we made you
all flying fish and your other case
that's that's that's great yeah so yeah
our product basically is built around
setting up a data source to just about
anything you might want to connect to
the amount of stuff yeah whether it's
you know kind of more managed CRM things
like Salesforce or Microsoft Dynamics or
you know homegrown Postgres database
that you set up or rest or connecting to
Google Maps and different api's and
stuff like that so it helped me go from
being on kind of the business II sales
into things to doing a lot of creative
and problem-solving stuff using
technology so it was really exciting I
love the product and so coming here I've
been interested in things like I
actually missed because we got turned
around you know country boys in the big
city missed there was a rapid
prototyping in public sector we've got a
number of public sector customers and so
we wanted to see you know how do you put
something in front of someone that looks
useful like what they want to see really
really quickly and then start iterating
and building on it that's what's really
exciting to me so we got to find an
encore of that yeah and everything was
recorded and if we managed to do it last
year everything should be on YouTube
within about 48 hours if not faster okay
awesome I don't know how many people
they have working in the video room but
they have a lot no kidding we're turning
around 20 in 30 sessions every hour Wow
yeah that's awesome this event is bigger
than some people's hometowns which I
found out yesterday absolutely well so
here's another plug speaking of that you
know we have our own dock site you know
we have our own but you get stuck first
thing you do well I google it you all
still own the first question I'm gonna
ask I'm gonna google it and the second
thing I'm going to do is YouTube it so
you're number one at number two just for
how do I do that thing I both super
appreciate that and I have a little bit
of potty humor going on in my head
there's an acceptable amount did you
podcast threshold well-played sir I was
gonna say we should we should probably
wrap up so we can let you guys get back
to the event yeah yes so much to see
like we literally stopped at JetBrains
because we've got some folks back at
squid that love Kotlin and IntelliJ yeah
that's it and then since we're hanging
out here in the podcast booth just
behind us is the industry section and
they've got some of the coolest demos in
my opinion okay cool so we have our can
they have our retail friends and our
gaming friends over there they're robots
anywhere I know there is a robot I found
saw yesterday I think it was over in the
machine learning section that way all
right cool my son is four and he loves
robots so if I could get a picture of a
robot I'm 36 and I love it here I'll
meet you it's not an age thing bots are
just cool oh no
everyone loves robots in gaming
absolutely it's pretty much awesome have
an awesome event yeah thank you thank
you
yeah thank you well I'm having a hard
time so wait these go on my ears
no I guess
I hope I hope you guys realize it this
may be the session of the week I'm
feeling good about this right now you
said a pretty high bar there can you
introduce yourself so we know who just
said they're gonna have the most
impressive I think that's why I'm
feeling it's organic I'm starting to
feel really good about this until I
looked at him having problems putting
those headphones on now this is Jose
plug on deployment lead from onyx and
imma go ahead and go on the record and
say that I think this might be the best
session of the week I think so even
started yet let's make it happen
else we have I am Brian Coco's I'm the
marketing director at onyx it's all shy
again and Brian Yan Brian so uh what
brings you all to next yeah we are a
Google partner one of the first Google
partners so obviously we're we're here
for that reason we are onyx from
Lakewood Ohio started in the 90s in the
networking business and kind of evolved
with technology and now we are a premier
Google partner in a multiple partner of
the Year winner and also one of the
first partners of Google phone on the
stage the first of first or second yet
it's one of those things that's argued
back and forth you know I just wanted
them so we have a database for that or
something we should know I think that
everybody here has data but you couldn't
get in until you had a database it's
just part of the and part of the entry
yeah everyone has a database but none of
them speak to each other no doubt that's
why I'm employed actually so we can help
connect all the databases together to
speak to each other differently mission
you do stand-up comedy
14 years 14 yeah I know it's a lot of
booze
now when you say booze is that spelled
v-loc oh oh wow I I misheard that -
everything is debatable on podcasts so
Brian also has some stand-up comedy
chops
yeah I didn't yeah I did stand-up for
about ten years then I met a woman and
my career pretty much ended I got
married and had kids and the rest of my
days and in bitterness
it seems like there would be some
potential content there are things to
talk about through those life there's
content yeah there's definitely content
but you get to the point in life where
it's just not really funny anymore when
you're the joke and you're living it
before we don't know what the content
looks like I think we have to check the
parental guidance ratings on this
podcast and weeks really yeah I don't
have this level of credentials on the
stand-up comedy and I'm sure there's a
lot of young kids or no swings you
elaborate on that a little bit for what
do you buy credentials I'm curious I
mean years of experience user experience
years of torment
it could be are we talking about tech or
company now why not both no doubt that's
the best part about it I think that we
bridge the gap for both that's one of
our specialties you know the culture is
something special at onyx as well you
know it's like one big happy family
there's like this overlying synergy that
you know we work hard play hard I mean I
hang out with these people you know
outside of work a ton so it's fun to
come to an event like this I'm not gonna
lie when I saw the podcast my eyes lit
up because I think this is a great idea
in the middle of it all and you guys got
a great location you know right here and
we've got this super stylish house it's
very stylish it is very nice it's very
green I was gonna say the green house or
it looks like an old photo Matt oh my
gosh you're dating yourself and I hate
the fact that I know what you mean with
the drive-in photo mats yeah exactly I
mean the the digital camera and the
Polaroid picture years exactly really
give those weird roles that fit right in
and then you had to get them developed
and it took like five years and then
after you haven't developed you're
moving from like dorm room the dorm room
you still found 30 rolls or undeveloped
this is like never developing we're
gonna see how old they are in a minute
because they're looking at us kind of
puzzling I'm looking at you I'm not
looking at you funny I'm just
remembering all those years I spent in
darkroom spooling film so that I could
develop it so yeah that was lots of fun
yeah
yeah and you're dating yourself there
that because above the time about the
time that you finished that learning all
that that's when the digital age you're
developing the film so let me ask you
how long did you work at the photo
houses I did it for fun cuz I I had bad
hobbies I was gonna say wow I like to
play in chemistry set it was fun okay so
what are you getting excited about at
the conference like is there any session
you're looking forward to or any product
announcements or you know parties any
obviously I'm gonna be the blame guy in
here I mean I'm not really I've been to
a couple parties already with with
Google and the reception last night to
kick things off was pretty cool I mean
the food was fantastic yeah that was
great it was awesome
I just I'm more around the technology
side of things you know and seeing what
everybody brings to the table you know
my division is enterprise search so I'm
probably not play favorites here I've
been in a couple great cloud search
sessions that have also been an awesome
cloud platform session - it was really
cool stuff it's my first time in next so
I'm kind of an extra key have you seen
any interesting stories of people what
people are doing research or like you
said enterprise and search and so I was
curious like there any awesome stories
that you're allowed to share it in a
nutshell think of Google for your
internal you know use case so you own a
company and you have a huge amount of
data you have no way to find it you know
one of our popular use cases which I'll
just talk about because that was in the
last session was Philips health care
where their Tech's you know had a ton of
data but they didn't know how to bring
it together in order to do repairs on
healthcare equipment you know CT
machines and cat scans and all those
types of pieces of equipment and stuff
so it allowed them to put it all in one
central location and then bring it into
a use case so that people doing service
on those machines I mean the overlying
downtime of those machines was improved
with almost by 30 percent
so this is like being able to like
search for the error message but for
this like really particular correct so
that error message that they would find
like a technician would find it would be
in this huge handbook of like thousands
of pages and they'd have to take that oh
this is error message code you know j7
three five Niner I did it a Niner in
there and then they would go and look
for the headphones you know and take
forever you know I know the headphones
were appropriate I feel like I've got
some sort of pilot right now I'm going
into my Niner face but yeah and it would
take them just a long time to make a fix
and itemize what the problem was from an
analytical standpoint in order to target
that fix immediately that improves
productivity decreases downtime helps
them make that fix a lot quicker so it's
pretty pretty cool stuff when there's a
good use case part in the thing about
that too is it really transcends
industry so you know one of the things
that you have to think about is the baby
boomers are retiring and mass right now
and so what you have going on what we
call an institutional memory loss so in
the instance that you were talking about
with Philips health care I actually used
to work for Phillips Medical Systems and
worked in radiology yeah so I know it
all too well so what happens and it
happens in every line of work you have
people that retire you know get fired
you know leave whatever it is and what
they do is they take with them all that
knowledge that they built up over the
years that's institutional knowledge and
what happens is there's a giant vacuum
there's a gap so something like
Enterprise Search you know helps address
that by getting everything all that
information all that data on the cloud
so people can you know readily find it
you know otherwise you have situations
that I've been in this situation before
where we've had someone they leave a job
you know it's shut down part of what we
were actually doing because nobody knew
what to do at that point
yeah the now is management piece is huge
in regards to that and then that's just
one of the many products and we were all
wearing on spend shirts today on spends
another one of our products it adds like
a cloud billing software we're very big
in the GCP we're very big in 2g sweet
juice which another one of our yeah did
you have any like favorite announcements
from the
event so far further than that so so far
I think I'm looking forward to the you
know seeing what goes on it like the
awards city I think will be kind of cool
that's always exciting you know for a
lot of different folks you know and also
just you know walking around and seeing
all the different booths and all the
technologies and seeing that that cloud
icon right there and see how many times
that you actually been used for alcohol
I've actually seen that about six or
seven times another look and those in
those poor folks that have that cloud
icon or that that logo and realize it
yeah yeah we were the only ones that
thought maybe we come up with a logo
with a cloud on it no one else would
come up with that and you're going on a
whole nother level of copyright
infringement that we need to pull onyx
legal and I think yeah I think back on
what you're saying though all joking
aside is no the bridging of different
backgrounds and different organizations
different demographics people all over
the world that come across and you
finally need to see them face to face it
use your products you know and talk
about how much of a benefit it is in
their organization you know or even
people you work with I mean there's
people I've never met before I know them
via email and I just know their little
head shot via email I'm like I know you
and then you know all of a sudden you're
actually getting to meet them and you
know and and you know I'm realizing
they're not as nice as you thought they
were going to we're gonna be compelling
and intriguing why not go it'll go full
monty on that one I love how you're
pushing the envelope right now I'm
telling you you're preaching my you know
you're speaking my language
like even Jose I mean I think we met
like the first day my first day there
and Jose came in you know we're talking
I find out that he's a stand-up comic I
mean how many stand-up comics work at
that place - I thought I thought a
couple of them so we've never like you
know but on stage about claims our CEO
and owner and I won't say this because
he's not he's actually a really funny
guy he is how many times face I'll never
don't never tell me to mind this may end
up you know where it's gonna be on the
Internet I mean that's far I found
listen if he does then you know he could
see here my little secret but I don't
even know if the guy checks his email
yet
he does we have such a great
relationship at work and everybody has
so much fun but the thing about Islands
when we all come together is there's one
collective whole that's the client you
know client satisfaction huge to us it's
just hey we just found a way to you know
perfect having fun while doing it
awesome
well here's to more gatherings and
meeting people and connecting all the
every building stuff absolutely thanks
for the invite if you guys ever stopped
by the Cleveland office stop on over I
mean we have you know little our basic
googly we have a lot of fun games and
stuff so I know a lot of people don't
like to come to Cleveland that's like
the running joke over there they're like
relocated my god we're in Cleveland like
oh what's it Cleveland the Browns
it's like the hottest team the talking
yes I'm saying
the one guy last night at the partner
reception kind of laughed in my face
when I said that we're three to five
years away from a Super Bowl and he's
yes how many drinks I had to be honest
wait wait wait wait would you say three
to five three to five years away from
super hot standby that how about one is
on the radio sports Tosh one other last
but actually a lot of companies talk
about corporate social responsibility
team needles is our CEO and really lives
it I almost jumped in announcement that
we have some but we do a lot with the
homeless and in terms of yeah yeah we
have a property then him and his wife
created called onyx outreach it helps
fight you know hunger and homelessness
and Cleveland Wow oh it's fantastic yeah
check out the website and for them to
give back like that is a direct relation
on who they are as people and we were
fascinating people to work with and and
and the thing is the whole company's
involved in that it's actually written
into our HR what do we get a day we get
one for
year one to do volunteer wife at work
it's not and then you know throughout
the rest of the year everybody helps out
with I mean every year around
Christmastime we do like clothing and
food drive I mean we work with some of
the most considerate and platinum
hearted individuals across the planet
I'm pretty sure saying that there's not
even a joke oh that's just fact I think
that's why we're all there to answer
really problem it definitely it
definitely pushes you for it as an
employee it's something that's inspiring
and it just makes you a better person
you know you want to make it better than
awesome thanks for being here nice
meeting you guys thank you so much thank
you to everyone for joining us today
with these awesome episodes live from
the Google next show floor please tune
in tomorrow for another episode with
more interviews for more attendees at
this conference fantastic see you then
[Music]